[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las historias y noticias
de Medio Oriente América Latina Esto es
lo que veremos en nuestro programa de
hoy Turquía reactivó sus ataques sobre
posiciones kurdas en el kurdistán de
Irak y Siria ankara no esconde su
intención de llevar a cabo una nueva
invasión terrestre en Siria mientras
Irán también está bombardeando la región
del kurdistán iraní donde continúan las
protestas por la muerte de Max a mini la
selección de iraní fue eliminada del
mundial de fútbol de Qatar algo que pese
a la pasión por el fútbol dentro de la
República islámica muchos iraníes
contrarios al régimen celebran La
derrota y aprovecharon el altavoz del
torneo para mostrar su apoyo a las
protestas antigubernamentales El Cairo
la capital de Egipto sería la ciudad más
peligrosa para las mujeres que sufren
violencia sistemáticas y a menudo
silenciadas por un sistema
local y conservador poco a poco las
egipcias apoyadas por las organizaciones
feministas están alzando sus voces
iniciamos en Turquía porque el
presidente allí perdogan continúa sus
ataques sobre posiciones kurdas de Siria
e Irak una campaña contra los
combatientes kurdos aquí en ankara
considera como terroristas Turquía culpa
a los kurdos por el reciente ataque
mortal con bomba en Estambul algo que
los kurdos por su parte están negando
ahora también ankara amenaza con una
nueva y posible incursión en el norte de
Siria para analizar Esto está con
nosotros Carlos turutuza Él es
periodista especializado en el
curtistant Carlos vemos una nueva oleada
de ataques turcos en las regiones kurdas
de Siria e Irak A qué se deben estos
nuevos bombardeos o si realmente habían
cesado anteriormente
Sí bueno Esto no es nuevo no
erdogan sigue esta campaña de expulsar a
los kurdos del norte de Siria lo vimos
en afrin en un en un territorio de
mayoría curda cuya población expulsó en
2018 y la sustituyó por por refugiados
árabes de otras partes del país y dejó
la región en manos de milicias
yihadistas en las que a las que dio un
uniforme en 2019 lo volvimos a ver y
este año lo intentó hacer lo que pasa es
que en un principio Rusia y Rusia e Irán
le dijeron que no
aprovechando la debilidad de
de Rusia en Ucrania y que Terán está en
horas bajas pues se ha lanzado a ello no
erdogan se está reforzando con o sea se
está saliendo reforzado con la Guerra de
Ucrania
y sabe que
Que bueno que su país es imprescindible
para la otan y bueno entre otras cosas
tiene el veto este impuesto a Finlandia
y a Suecia que todavía está en
negociaciones entonces aprovecha esta
coyuntura aprovecha justo este momento
para lanzar un ataque más sobre los
sobre los kurdos de Siria y expulsarlos
en la frontera
Y qué podría pasar si se recrudecen
estos ataques para la población civil
kurda y también si Turquía realiza una
invasión terrestre en el norte de Siria
Bueno lo que puede pasar es lo que ha
pasado en ocasiones anteriores
desplazamientos masivos de población
civil hablamos de cientos de miles de
personas expulsadas de sus casas y no
solo no solo curdo sino Árabes y toda
toda esta gente que vive en la frontera
luego hemos visto que la tecnología de
Turquía sobre todo en el tema de los
drones pues es muy efectiva lo estamos
viendo en Ucrania lo vimos en Libia y
[Música]
sin controlar el aire los kurdos
difícilmente pueden hacer frente a un
ejército como el Turco no
la pregunta es si como dice se llegará a
esos extremos de Invasión terrestres es
decir fuerzas que Probablemente sean las
mismas que antes las tropas estas
yihadistas a las que da un uniforme y
les llama el ejército nacional sirio
Carlos También estamos viendo como Terán
está atacando a los kurdos iraníes
precisamente Allí es donde siguen más
activas las protestas que se vienen
sucediendo desde la muerte de la joven
iraní Max a mini Cómo es el papel de las
mujeres kurdas dentro del movimiento de
liberación kurdo
bueno Empezando por el por el por el
lema de las manifestaciones que es yin
ya nazadi como dicen en kurdo que es
mujer vida y Libertad Este es un lema
que adaptado el movimiento de liberación
kurdo el pkka ya por 2013 y es un lema
que escuchábamos a las a las
combatientes kurdas en Siria cuando
luchaban contra el estado islámico no
entonces la mujer en lo que es el
movimiento Liberación kurdo tiene un
papel
bueno fundamental
preponderante desde el principio y eso
estamos eso lo hemos visto en el norte
de Siria donde hay un sistema de cuotas
50-50 en el que en el que la
representación y el liderazgo está
repartido a medias entre hombres y
mujeres lo estamos viendo en su
estructura política tanto la legal como
La ilegal
y estamos viendo que eso también prende
en Irán no donde evidentemente los
partidos políticos kurdos son ilegales
hablamos de un movimiento que está
completamente en la clandestinidad pero
estamos viendo que está mucho más
organizados de lo que de lo que los
clérigos les gustaría no
Y como te decía es Es una de las marcas
de la ideología del pkka el partido y
los trabajadores del kurdistán cuyo cuyo
fundador y ha ideólogo principal está en
la cárcel desde 1999 Muchas gracias
Carlos sobre Tusa periodista español
especializado en el curtistán por estar
con nosotros en France 24 y en medio de
la Euforia del mundial de fútbol de
Qatar los activistas contrarios al
régimen iraní han conseguido desafiar no
solo las políticas de su país también
las políticas de la FIFA partido tras
partido los manifestantes se han pintado
el rostro o han introducido pancartas a
los estadios en apoyo a las masivas
protestas que se vienen sucediendo en
Irán desde el asesinato de la joven Max
a mini el pasado septiembre Irán quedó
eliminada del mundial tras su partido
con Estados Unidos y nos lo cuenta desde
doha nuestro enviado especial Juan
pupiales
el conflicto social de Irán se ha hecho
sentir en esta copa mundo desde antes
incluso de que Irán debutará en este
mundial con declaraciones como las del
jugador exchanghasafi que dijo que las
condiciones en su país no son las
correctas el equipo Irán y la selección
de iraní que se negó a cantar el himno
nacional en ese Debut en esa derrota
contra Inglaterra ha sido una atención
que se ha sentido en el campo pero
también fuera de él desde que llegamos
aquí en cada partido de Irán en cada uno
de sus tres partidos que Irán disputó en
la fase de grupos hemos visto
aficionados que querían expresar su
rechazo al gobierno incluso llevando la
bandera previo de la Revolución islámica
llegó a ver algún intento de mostrar el
nombre de Max a mini en un estadio algo
que fue frustrado porque en los
mundiales de fútbol se impide que se
muestre cualquier tipo de eslogan que se
interprete como político particularmente
estas sanciones tuvieron un episodio más
álgido en el último partido de Irán
contra Estados Unidos en esta fase de
grupos cuando un grupo de aficionados
iraníes que llevaban camisetas en apoyo
a las mujeres de este país comenzó a ser
agredido por otro grupo de aficionados
podríamos decir que estaban a favor del
gobierno iraní la seguridad del estadio
que reaccionó poniendo en una zona de
seguridad a esos aficionados que estaban
siendo agredidos mientras intentaba
frustrar los intentos de este equipo de
France 24 por grabar esas imágenes fue
una vez más una demostración en esta
copa mundo de que el fútbol casi siempre
va de la mano de la realidad social de
los países
y cambiamos de tema 2022 ha sido el año
más violento para los palestinos con más
de 150 víctimas mortales por ataques de
soldados israelís unas muertes que se
suceden prácticamente a diario dentro de
los territorios ocupados palestinos
Naciones Unidas instó a todas las partes
a poner el cc a esta violencia
sistemática mientras las fuerzas
israelíes continúan su campaña militar
de incursiones y arrestos masivos nos lo
cuenta desde Jerusalén nuestra
corresponsal Yanira Gómez Muñoz
2022 es Ya el año más mortífero para los
palestinos en cisjordania ocupada al
menos desde 2006 pues las fuerzas
israelíes han matado a más de 150 entre
milicianos civiles y menores palestinos
estas muertes se cuentan casi a diario y
muchas ocurren en enfrentamientos
desiguales con el ejército no obstante
algunas también son consecuencia de las
violentas redadas y de los más de 3.000
arrestos que Israel ha intensificado
sobre todo en jenning a raíz de los
ataques en primavera que causaron la
muerte de 19 israelíes no hay que
olvidar que en agosto 48 palestinos
murieron en gaza por los bombardeos
iniciados por Israel y los cohetes de la
yihad islámica Palestina y esta
violencia se teme que empeore con el
próximo gobierno israelí liderado por
tercera vez por Benjamín netanyahu y en
el que políticos radicales
ultrareligiosos y ultranacionalistas
tendrán mayor poder de decisión por
ejemplo itamar vengivir anti árabe
colono en un asentamiento y partidario
de la anexión total de cisjordania será
ministro de seguridad y podría controlar
la policía de fronteras en los
territorios palestinos ocupados su
figura es la antítesis de una seguridad
para los palestinos que además de las
incursiones militares este año han
sufrido también un recrudecimiento de
los ataques de colonos judíos
y el pasado 25 de noviembre se conmemoró
el Día Mundial por la eliminación de las
violencias contra las mujeres desde hace
cinco años la capital de Egipto El Cairo
fue calificada como la ciudad más
peligrosa del mundo para las mujeres el
99% de sus habitantes declararon haber
sido acosada sexualmente una violencia
cotidiana y sistemática sumida en los
tabús de una sociedad conservadora
Clarín Williams nos trae la historia
vengan voy a mostrarles lo que me queda
de chaima el 24 de Julio la vida de
Magda dio un giro radical su hija Jaime
gamal presentadora de televisión de 42
años Fue asesinada por su marido Un
conocido juez de la capital
tras un juicio mediatizado a principios
de septiembre el hombre y su cómplice
fueron condenados a muerte la madre de
shayma sigue sin entender bat estabas
WhatsApp
siete años de matrimonio y este traidor
la mata de la peor manera no estamos
hablando de un hombre ignorante y sin
educación no es un hombre muy poderoso
nunca sospechábamos de él
según un informe de las Naciones Unidas
de 2015 más de 5 millones de mujeres
egipcias son Víctimas de violencia
conyugal cada año sin embargo Hay pocas
estructuras que las acojan
en esta ong reciben formación
trabajadora sociales y abogadas para
ayudar a las víctimas la asociación ha
recibido casi 600 mujeres este año una
cifra que no cesa de aumentar
recibimos a mujeres que son maltratadas
físicamente y en muchos casos el marido
está desempleado y consume drogas
ante una sociedad que sigue siendo
profundamente conservadora las mujeres
egipcias siguen luchando para que sus
derechos sean respetados gracias a las
redes sociales sus voces se hacen oír en
el verano de 2020 La ola del mitu se
extendió por Egipto
[Música]
pájaro
al año siguiente el gobierno transformó
el delito de acoso en un crimen
castigado con penas más severas Este
cambio de legislación fue acogido con
satisfacción por la ONU en su momento la
propia prensa egipcia informa ahora de
los casos de violencia contra las
mujeres nadie mabruck tenía 3 años
cuando sus tíos irrumpieron en su casa
le dispararon a su madre ocho veces su
error había sido casarse con un beduino
de una tribu diferente
necesitaba escribir ese artículo
Necesitaba hablar porque había guardado
silencio durante demasiado tiempo se
está corriendo la voz y la lucha
feminista está creciendo Aunque el
camino hacia la libertad todavía aparece
largo las mujeres egipcias están
decididas a recorrerlo
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir
toda la información en nuestra página
web France 24.com
[Música]